hi folks i'm gabe weiss a developer
advocate for google cloud
today i'd like to introduce you to a new
product database migration service or
dms
i'm also going to walk through a quick
simple migration to cloud sql using it
database migration service makes it fast
and easy to move your mysql or postgres
database
to our manage cloud sql service dms
provides a simple
integrated experience to guide you
through every step of the migration
it's serverless so you don't need to
worry about managing or monitoring
instances
and continuous data replication means
you can cut over with minimal downtime
whether your database is on-premise
self-hosted in google cloud
or running on another cloud dms helps
you quickly unlock the benefits of
manage cloud sql
now let's walk through the dms
experience for a new migration job
you can access dms from the google cloud
console navigation
under databases just click database
migration
to get started you'll create a migration
job this represents the end-to-end
process of moving your source database
to a cloud sql destination
first let's define what kind of
migration the job will run
i want to move a mysql database i am
running on gce
to cloud sql
i can choose between one time or
continuous replication
i'll select continuous for minimal
downtime
once i've defined my job dms shows me
the source and connectivity
configuration required to be able to
connect to
and migrate the source database dms
makes it easy to know what i need to do
to prepare by showing me the
prerequisites directly in the ui
it also supports the setup of multiple
networking connectivity options
including secure
private connectivity with built-in
scripts for easy execution
if i need to make changes to the
configuration of my source database
i can click save and exit to pick up
where i left off later
i'm ready to define my source i can do
this by creating a connection profile
a resource that represents the
information needed to connect to a
database
these profiles aren't locked to an
individual migration this means i can
reuse it if i want to first test out a
migration
or if someone else in my organization is
in charge of connecting to the database
i've already created a connection
profile for my sql database running on
gce so i'll select it
now i'm ready to create the cloud sql
instance that i'll migrate my database
to
this will feel familiar to anyone that's
created a cloud sql instance before
you'll see many of the same options like
connectivity and machine configuration
dms relies on the replication technology
of the database engine
i don't have to create resources aside
from the cloud sql instance i've just
defined
i'm ready to define how my new instance
will securely connect to my source
database for continuous data replication
i have a few options i can choose to
allow list the ip address of the cloud
sql destination on the database sources
machine
i can set up private connectivity
through a reverse ssh tunnel on a vm in
my project
or i can set up vpc peering since my
source is already running on google
cloud i'll choose vpc pairing
and that was easy i've configured my
source created a cloud sql destination
and established connectivity between
them all that's left is to validate the
migration job setup and start my
migration my migration job validation
passed successfully
i can trust that my migration will run
smoothly
i'll create and start the job to run it
immediately
once my migration job is started i can
monitor its progress and see if it
encounters
any issues dms will first transfer the
initial snapshot of existing data
then continuously replicate changes as
they happen
and since dms is serverless i never have
to worry about the migration resources
themselves
that's it i've quickly and easily shown
you one of the ways to migrate a mysql
database out of gce
and into cloud sql using dms when the
initial snapshot's migrated and
continuous replication is keeping up
i can promote cloud sql to be my primary
instance and point my applications to
work directly against it
google cloud's new database migration
service is the fast easy and reliable
way to migrate with minimal downtime to
a manage cloud sql database
for both mysql and postgres it's
serverless
high performance and free to use now
it's your turn to give it a try
you can get started from the google
cloud console or learn more by following
the links in the description
thanks for watching
[Music]
you